-We're hanging out
with Allison Janney!
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Allison, your show "Mom"
is about a mother-daughter
relationship.
So in honor of that, we thought
we'd try something fun.
We asked people online
to help us out
by sending in
some real text exchanges
that they've had with their mom.
And I thought that we could read
some of our favorites together.
It is time for
"Dramatic Mom Texts."
-♪ "Dramatic Mom Texts" ♪
♪ "Dramatic Mom Texts" ♪
-Alright, you should know
that all these texts are real.
For the texts,
you'll be playing the mom,
and I will be playing
the son or daughter.
Does that sound good?
-Copy that.
-Perfect.
Alright, great.
Here we go.
We'll begin
whenever you're ready.
-Okay.
"Sweetheart, don't forget
to unload the dishwasher.
Did you finish your homework?
We have to go to
your grandmother's house
for Thanksgiving.
Dad and I talked.
We are going to buy you a car
next month."
-"U are???
Omg thank u."
-Yeah.
"No. We're not.
I just wanted to make sure
you were getting my texts."
-"That was cruel."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Okay.
Let's do another.
I'll start.
-Okay.
-"Hi, Mom."
-"Waving hand emoji."
[ Laughter ]
-"How are you?"
-"Thumbs up emoji."
[ Laughter ]
-"What's for dinner?"
-"Pizza emoji."
-"Why don't you just use
the actual emojis?"
-"Don't know how!
Sad emoji."
-[ Laughs ]
That is fun.
For this next one,
Allison, you'll start.
-Okay. Okay.
[ Clears throat ]
-Yep.
-"What's the song
like doodads bop
maybe by the Jonas Brothers
or some boy band?"
-"Hmm. I'm not sure."
-"Doodads Bop.
Bop Doodads Doodad Bop.
Doodad Bop Doodad
Bop Bop Doodads."
-"'MMMBop' by Hanson?"
-"Yes!
I'm making a playlist for you."
-[ Laughs ]
Doodads bop.
[ Laughs ]
Alright.
Let's do another one here.
You will start.
-I will start.
-Mm-hmm.
-"Andyidontknowwhere
thespacebaris."
[ Laughter ]
-"It's in the middle
at the bottom.
It's labeled 'SPACE.'"
[ Laughter ]
-"Idontseeitandy
couldyoubemorespecific?"
-"I don't know how much clearer
I could be."
-"I found it!"
-[ Laughs ]
Alright.
Let's do another.
This time I'll start.
Here we go.
-Okay. Wait. Okay. Alright.
-Ready?
-Okay. Yeah.
-"Mom, where are you?"
-"Leaving Walmart.
Halfway home.
Why, sweetie?"
-"You brought me
to Walmart with you."
[ Laughter ]
-"Oh, darn!
Be there in a bit."
-[ Laughs ]
-My thanks to Allison Janney!
You can see the final season
of "Mom"
Thursdays at 9:00 p.m. on CBS.
I'll never forget this.